start number three for tony gonzalen
no runs over eight and two thirds so far
jp crawford climbs in
godzilla winds and throws and off we go
with a first pitch fly ball to center
field
cody bellinger is there one pitch one on
dylan moore comes up
moore swats one to right for bets two up
and two down
there's a good young player right here
in kyle lewis
and a fastball is lifted into the bright
sunshine bat shading his eyes with his
glove and makes the catch to finish off
a one two three first for godzilla
for marco his first career start against
the dodgers his fifth start this year
[Music]
[Applause]
little more is able to make the catch
and keep his feet
corey seeger three run home runs in
back-to-back games
dylan chasing after this in the corner
and foul ground and he makes the catch
turner in 11-game hit streak
good pitch for marco on the edge his
first strikeout retires the dodgers in
order
baron is nothing the dodgers nothing we
go to the top half of the second
the 2-2 and volvo ball swings and misses
that ends the inning on the change-up
six up six down well we had to the
bottom half of the second here at
dodgers stadium no score
here's the stretch and the one-two on
the way in a swing and a miss and an
off-speed pitch for strike three so
gonzales strikes out aj pollock
here's center fielder cody bellinger
talk about taking it i mean that is
exactly what you're wanting to see
three strikeouts in a row chris taylor
former mariner
and a swing and a foul tip into the
glove of nola for strike three and marco
gonzalez
strikes out the side here in the bottom
half of the second here's the one-two
pitch to muncie breaking ball
and there for a call strike and muncie
knew it that's
five consecutive strikeouts for marco
gonzalez three of them
turner over one he struck out in the
first the pitch on the way breaking ball
swinging a fly ball
right center feeling deep more going
back lewis going back lewis with a leap
and he makes the catch
at the top of the wall and right center
field
holy smokes what a catch by
kyle lewis justin turner way back into
the gap
and with a full head of steam kyle going
back to the wall
at the top of the fence brings it back
what a play by lewis one away
oh the stash loves it so does marco
gonzalez
here's bellinger why don't you just do
the rest of the ending
it goes around another stretch out for
marco
he's got six bottom of the fifth inning
leading things off for the dodgers left
fielder chris taylor and a swing and a
miss by taylor for strike three that's
the second time marco has fan chris
taylor
and that is strikeout number seven he
wears a strikeout total on his back the
wind-up band the o2 pitch the
at that muncies strikeouts for marco
gonzalez he's one
shy of a career best 2-2 coming
strike three he got him nine strikeouts
for marco gonzalez he has matched his
career best
turnover the two-hour chance here on the
six to put godzilla in position to win
the game
[Applause]
bouncing ball through the left side base
hit gordon's up with it
barnes comes home the throw is laid in
the dodgers lead
justin turner delivers with two going
here in the six
pitch number eight to pollock
seeger on first dodgers get an rbi
single from justin turner we go to the
top of the seventh la 1
the mariners nothing scott alexander
he's going to take on tim lopes who's
going to pinch hit for vogelback
chopping the third this is a time game
tim lopes brings home kyle lewis and we
are right back where we started here in
the seventh
one out one on bottom seven and here's
max muncie
jp the tag the throw what a play
that'll work jp crawford showing off the
leather
1-1 game top of the eighth 900 d gordon
grounds the first pitch right back to
alexander who throws
high to first muncie climbing the ladder
to bail him out
your number one pitch is a sinking
fastball nice behind the back grab but
uh throw the sinker over there
hey look what i got in my back pocket
wow
bam didn't realize that in real time
that's awesome play
picking their spots here barnes stealing
second
three and two on corey seeger here comes
out to villa
seeger grounds one through the right
side base hit
here comes barnes moore's throw is light
and the dodgers take the lead in the
eighth barn still second
seeger promptly drives him in dodgers
two to one two out of the ninth there's
tim
lopes ground ball to seeger he's got
this one cleanly
that's the ball game the dodgers win it
2-1
trining gets the last five outs and one
day after an 11-9 slugfest
they do the little things and they win
it 2-1